oh why hello there brass welcome to
another episode of Dark Soul [ __ ]
[Music]
this place looks wonderful love it
this place is filled with tracks are you
serious hahaha come on oh god am I gonna
fight in here
oh god oh god I hid aha oh [ __ ]
no I would do me with your hand no oh
god no oh my god that luck ah what are
you [ __ ] this fortress today our chests
nice Oh God traps [ __ ] it chanced
everywhere this is another trap isn't it
Oh what
that's its time they're deaf have a
balanced
oh god this camping it stop judging me
oh no they shoot me oh [ __ ] oh god
what's happens down here I'm done come
at me bro
come at me bro that's what happens bro
Oh God Oh goddamn it I really love the
Holborn I don't know if how long I can
keep it or should keep it ah for [ __ ]
sake so the plan here is to distract him
with my sexy white silver hair 9 foot a
hem the better off not dead gonna be
dead any second now there it is there it
is waited for it it's nice when you took
a break from a game and come back and
you're [ __ ] worse come on ball come
on balls that's my ball I never [ __ ]
make this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my ass gah bah I don't trust anything
in this [ __ ] hellhole
remember where I went oh yeah it's the
[ __ ] me elevator in the ass you don't
take it on the way up that's that's
something I learned we don't trust that
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] chef I'm a funny
handler back there don't you
what
why the AI in this [ __ ] game and
sometimes it's hilarious hey man how you
doing up there oh god oh god Indiana
Jones [ __ ] Chuck that killed me why are
you [ __ ] serious I really should have
picked a female character tonight
well we can go up here I know that how
did I miss the hell that's definitely
attractive [ __ ] don't trap me bro oh god
don't really all God press on here
nope a [ __ ] can you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
even have a [ __ ] shield
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] now how oh god what
did I do now oh god damn it he jumps
after it's fine he's gonna Jess you
piece of [ __ ] let me get dressed you
dirty perv why did I take away my Sheila
I didn't even have to do that [ __ ] oh
look it's just like they're like what do
I do now the [ __ ] am I supposed to die
slumbering okay I'll take it wherever it
reduces produces no sound so we can
sneak and [ __ ] all right oh she's fun
what is that
what huh no you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Dada Dada Dada you [ __ ] [ __ ] well
let's do that [ __ ] again Oh for [ __ ]
sake where did you come from
mm-hmm okay I know you're there you'll
[ __ ] let's just do it the badass way or
as I like to call it the stupidest
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] way when you
use a job that do me vent [ __ ] this
[ __ ] [ __ ] not gonna fall down from
you you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass-licking
oh [ __ ] me in there hello
no you idiot you were fine
it was fine it was fine it was fine
in a Turkish Europe and I wish this game
wasn't so easy the tactic is to not
[ __ ] fall down
[ __ ] you oh I'm coming for you ah ah god
damn what a lucky ass I have no more
tries no more [ __ ]
you [ __ ] insolent octopus there says
bounce never made it this far never made
it this far never made it this white
light please don't be mean to me white
light what the [ __ ] is that guy gonna do
with that ball
Oh we're outside this is so nice look at
that it's so beautiful what ow ow
wasted bean fire girls wait to bump my
girl hey you know what it would be great
Oh a [ __ ] bonfire how about that this
is this is gonna be bad
don't throw [ __ ] at me girl oh my god
damn it don't have any esters oh I know
I know god damn it I want it hey uh
sorry I mom I gotta go this way we cool
yeah we cool okay let's see let's see he
fee if he's a fan of arrows looks so
funny poor guy he's having a really bad
day this guy how [ __ ] bang you shoot
whoa nice roll bro nice roll bro keep
rolling and maybe one day you'll roll to
heaven I see you discovered the circle
button most excellent sir you see having
a shield is awesome means you can't
[ __ ] touch this you [ __ ] Oh what if
you drop and every Chad's Piper that
sounds gay great that sounds great god
damn it where am I supposed to go oh oh
I can jump oh you came up here I'm
[ __ ] see that [ __ ] what's up here
whoa whoa whoa don't [ __ ] with that guy
I guess very sham bye-bye
well I guess some people just don't like
it from behind should we go through the
white light ah nice tonight
Oh God iron golem hey how are you mad oh
god oh god oh god okay we're playing
yeah you can do that attack that's good
and that uh oh [ __ ] me was that an
insect that was an instant camp one out
of many more attempts that's doing the
camera angles are really not on my side
in this boss fight can he jump off that
is the [ __ ] question
oh god please jump off and she's so
funny oh god he stumps that no musical
[ __ ] fab those leggies allah his little
jumps they're adorable that one leg fab
the other leg what is he doing what is
he doing
just under some [ __ ] what no bad Dolan
his jumps are the cutest thing
Oh Oh aah yeah
second try my second trap though it was
pretty easy that's pretty easy
exterminate I don't even know why ah
[ __ ] this fortress man
[ __ ] this fortress may praise the Sun oh
god don't
oh that s no it's just like a part 1 of
a boss or some [ __ ] where the [ __ ] are
they taking me there what you wanted to
win my body oh it's pretty epic
holy [ __ ] sponsored by Disney thanks for
the ride oh god don't tell me that
there's no bonfire nice
brofist but I mean I love the Halbert
and I love this shield look at that look
at that it's gorgeous
oh [ __ ] but I just defeated the Bears
here on the bro channel we don't take
any [ __ ] chances especially with big
as bad as men oh god oh god oh god you
[ __ ] up now oh you don't like when I
tickle your face with arrows you have
you must be the first one I ever made
that does that [ __ ] I'm gonna have some
coffee you're not invited I'm sorry I'm
sorry you're not invited
oh god more of them Oh God okay and
maybe I should try and fight this one
what nope we're not fighting him it's
been great it's been great man I it's a
shame oh I'm so good
it's level up I'm gonna go over here oh
hey dude nice weather today isn't it can
I please no that cannot did mine it's
this fast get upgraded I have ten now
okay
head straight yonder if you're the
chosen one I feel like this is some kind
of weird test that if I keep walking
there will be on there will be like a
invisible bridge or some [ __ ] like that
hey you got a whole bar till we can be
homemade buddies well I guess not
okay okay I'm doing it invincible bridge
nope there was no [ __ ] guess okay
maybe I can kill him probably not but
you never know these things come out I
want to cut up is that an ass one to die
there you go
is there something here this like a
secret batch here and I went for the
invisible bridge cuz I'm smart like that
yeah am I supposed to walk on those it
feels stupid I don't think you can do
that but you don't know if you don't try
just be cool just like in school except
I never was never cool [ __ ] nailed that
[ __ ] hi alright my lives up here defin
tears that's what this game should be
called I'm pretty sure you don't want to
fall down here god damn it they just
love to make you fall down in this game
in yes right in the yes just as planned
I can't believe I haven't fallen down
yet I got I'm cat eyes on that statue
alright let's go they can't be a boss
right here right
can it whoa Oh what the [ __ ] he can't
come in here Oh what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] yeah this is [ __ ] killin can you
move please thank y'all why what a
[ __ ] idiot
whoa whoa did we get a halibut I'll bet
my god come on
Oh baby
yeah nice oh one more hit in his [ __ ]
then one more [ __ ] hit come on it's
you and me baby oh whoa
another halibut hell hey you are whoa
that is pretty heavy though
Oh God they don't look nice at all oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] these guys are tougher than
I thought
no yeah damn it
ah high price we're gonna have to take a
break eh I really hope you enjoy
watching I'd really love this game I
don't know if I'm getting better or if
the game is getting easier anyway thanks
for all the support in this serious
process I really appreciate it
maybe like I've enjoyed watching it
since guy to come birthday I'll see you
in the next day awesome
[Music]
you